hi there
day 85 you know i'm getting near the end
here i have to confess i didn't do much
today
uh i played golf with my wife
managed to get out of playing golf
tomorrow she's going with some friends i
managed to get out of that uh my
granddaughter's birthday this evening so
i didn't do much
uh i submitted some uh of my korean
writing for correction at our exchange
at link
and i got the corrections back i haven't
had a chance to to look at them so
tomorrow i've got to put some real
effort in i have a discussion lined up
with clara one of our tutors someone
asked me again how do i type korean on
the ipad so i can't really show that
because it the light shining on the ipad
i can't really show it but it's
extremely simple you can choose
different uh key keyboards for the ipad
as you can on a mac i don't know on
other computers so i can choose korean i
have a russian keyboard a czech spanish
chinese you name it
once you are in that language keyboard
then the little dictation icon
is linked to the language of the
keyboard
so then i can either type in korean and
i type by
pointing my finger at the keys on the
keyboard that are on the screen of the
ipad
or i can dictate and then it'll produce
the text more or less accurately
so i mean it's it's just very simple if
you have an ipad it's it's very handy
and as i said you just avoid the all the
mouse action so it's really quite
convenient um
and um yeah so i hope to do more writing
tomorrow i again thank my son for
you know basically
shaming me into starting to write i have
been writing more now and i feel more
confident when reading
so and i i know about as i've said
before i know that writing is important
i've just been too lazy to do it
um that's about it today was a very slow
day um
and quite honestly it's now 9 30. i'm
going to have a peek at
schuster live see what's happening there
uh after a while you know you see all
these politicians i must say the
politicians in the in ukraine i mean
they just
i mean
like this one fellow who was a candidate
for presidency he was in discussion with
some guy who was
involved in demonstrations in nikolai
effendi morales said you know you talk
pretty tough what if i show up and the
guy said well you just come so next
thing you know the guy's in nikolajf and
the next you know there's a fight going
there i mean the the degree of
sort of um
bravado
bully tactics
uh lack of compromise
exaggerating to make a point
it's amazing i don't see how they will
ever
achieve any compromise
that's just my impression
i mean it's fun to watch it's a sport
it's almost like a blood sport
but i mean obviously my hope is that
everything calms down and
and that they come to some kind of
solution
certainly
opinion polls even very recently don't
show a majority of people in the east
being in favor
of joining up with russia
but there are obviously some very active
people who represent a segment of the
population and who have some resources
whether they come from
uh yanukovych's party uh hangers on with
them or
oligarchs or whatever other sources uh
they're certainly keeping all that
action alive there
so we will just hope i mean really
it's not up to the americans the
europeans or the russians to tell the
ukrainians how to run their affairs
and uh hopefully uh
sane uh you know minds will prevail
the subject of language always comes up
and it's it's kind of presented
sometimes in next like you can't
forbid me from using my language well of
course no one is perverting the russian
speakers from using their language on
the other hand uh i'm curious about the
issue of uh the language of instruction
in universities so i actually sent an
email to two eastern ukrainian
universities one in donetsk and one in
kharkov and i said here i am
canada blah blah blah they have websites
in english and there are some leading
universities in the east and kharkiv and
elsewhere
and i can't remember which ones i sent
them to and i said can you tell me what
is the language of instruction of the
courses at your university
i haven't got an answer yet so i don't
know but it seems to me that that
if what the minister of education said
in that interview that i heard about a
month ago
that in the universities they only offer
courses in english and ukrainian then i
think that's a real problem on the other
hand i hear these complaints you know uh
are the the you know donetsk republic or
whatever they're saying you know we're
we're tired of uh our school books teach
us history that's anti-russian and that
glorifies
people like
bandera and stuff like that well i mean
yanukovych has been in power for the
last however many years so it's not you
can't tie that necessarily to the group
that's now in power in in kiev and who
are in any case an interim government so
i really think that all this talk about
referendum is extremely premature i
think there should be a presidential rec
uh election and then a parliamentary
election and then they deal with their
issues um
you know that but that's me sitting on
the sidelines i have no influence on
what goes on there and really it's up to
them to figure these things out for
themselves but
um i'm going off to listen to uh
schuster live and he normally has
two people from opposing camps so the
eastern ukrainian and the western
ukrainian they're going out at hammer
and tar and it's good for my russian and
uh good for my ukrainian which is
gradually improving anyway talk to you
later bye